- You guys, I have got a treasure chest.
This is a very special treasure chest.
This treasure chest came
from Peter McKinnon.
This has been sitting,
mainly for a few weeks,
sitting over there waiting
because I didn't want to open it
unless I was doing this on camera.
So let's,
I don't even know how to open this.
Do I need to like, do I need tools?
I don't. I just need my
fingers and my brain.
So you guys might notice
that we have a little new set
because I decided to turn
my room into an Apple store
and then we didn't put it
back to how it was before.
So now we can have some
more room for activities,
or set pieces, and this is
gonna look so good back there.
Let's see what it looks
like before I open it.
I know you guys want me to open it,
but I just want to see.
Yeah, that's nice.
Put this skull on top of it.
Oh, that's nice.
It has my name on it. Like it's custom.
This is a custom pirates pleasure chest.
It's all very-
Wait. There's something on
the bottom, too, look at that.
Oh, wow.
This is pirate treasure.
(exciting music)
(metallic scraping)
So excited.
I really do feel like I
went out and I dug this up.
But I didn't.
I just went and got the mail.
Whoa, look at this. Look!
Oh man, what a great logo.
Lens caplets?
This is everything.
We always need these.
Look at that.
There's little stickers
so that we can label
all of our lenses.
This is so cool.
What is this?
Limited edition artisan crafted,
handmade in the USA.
What, do you know what this is?
Oh my God. This is so cool.
It's a tumbler that
started out as molten glass
took 20 minutes to create.
Uniquely mine?
One of one?
That's impressive. Oh
my God. This is so nice.
It's got a little skull on the bottom.
What?
This is incredible.
I've got to drink my latte out of this.
Something in here smells good.
Okay, I saw this on his Instagram.
It's the candle. But
look at this container.
It's like a little vintage can...
There it is.
Oh, this smells incredible.
Put your snout on that.
- [Man] Whoa.
- Ah, Yeah.
- [Man] Whoa!
- It smells so good.
If that's what pirates
smell like, sign me up.
I am gonna hit the high seas.
I wish they could smell it.
What is the scent?
It's incredible.
I bet Peter went down there and
looted the Titanic for this,
like he would do that.
What is this?
What is this? What is all this stuff?
There's so much treasure in here.
Like I don't even know where to start.
Whip it and stick it.
Stickers. Oh, wow.
These are neat.
Oh man. Look how cool these are.
I'm gonna put these on my Pelican case.
Oh, wait a minute!
I found my next tattoo.
This is it. This is it.
I love, I love knives.
I've been looking into 3D printing knives.
I found some incredible "CS Go" ones
that are currently in the works.
What's this?
Little notebooks!
These are so nice. I love the design.
I love the matte black.
More notes!
Write it or lose it.
These are so cool.
What is in here?
Is this a mask?
It is a mask.
Look at this detail. Check that out.
Like this is,
this is some serious quality.
We're not even done yet.
Captain's secret sauce.
What is this?
Oh my gosh. It's hot sauce.
Oh, no way.
It's the editor's secret recipe.
- [Man] Okay, so I need
to step my game up.
- I got to step my game up
because I don't have anything.
I don't have a single piece of merch.
I'm gonna put this on my
eggs tomorrow morning.
What's in here?
This knife goes very
well with its packaging.
Oh!
It's a pen.
Oh my gosh. This is for the
notes that we're gonna take.
(indistinct)
Wow. I'm gonna write,
I'm gonna write a note.
You cool.
You cool, dude.
Here, do you want a pen, too?
Tyler, I share the pen with you.
- [Man] Oh my gosh.
- Let me, I'll open it for you.
- [Man] Yo!
- Just to see if it's a different one.
- Yo!
- Yeah. You got to go write your notes.
We gotta, we gotta, we gotta get merch.
(majestic music)
The only type of pen that I
usually carry is a tactical pen.
That's basically for not writing.
This is really cool.
Wow, we're gonna be writing notes.
There's so much stuff in
here. We're not even done yet.
A zipper pool.
Oh, these are cool.
These are getting replaced on
all of my Lulu Lemon jackets.
- Here, Tyler, look.
For your zippers.
- Confession.
- What?
- [Man] I have these
on my backpack already.
- Really? No way.
Wow. And wait, there's
still something else.
We still have one more thing.
Everything about, I'm gonna,
I'm freaking out. Like what is this?
There's a small little
tiny box inside of here.
Shut up.
Oh my goodness.
This is so cute. Wait, does this open?
Does this? Oh, I thought this was it.
Is there something else in here?
Wait, I just thought it was a cool box.
What is this?
I just thought it was a box.
Oh my God.
Look how cool this is.
This is life pirate treasure.
Oh my God.
I'm freakin' out, man.
Look at this.
I think I need to get
a matching skull tattoo
on the other side.
What do you think?
I just thought that this was a cool box,
but little did I know that there
is a treasure inside of it.
Oh my gosh, a secret coin pouch?
This is the coolest thing I've ever seen.
Like nothing else is ever
gonna compare to this.
What a freaking sweet
surprise. I'm so happy.
Thank you so much. This is incredible.
- [Man] Thank you!
(majestic music)
♪ Ooh, see the sun ♪